.
Oh, he's through.
Oh, no way.
That's a bad call.
Oh, that's so unproppable.
Was that an obstruction?
That was an obstruction.
Apparently.
I don't know.
That's a beautiful play.
That's a really nice play.
Yeah, it was a nice play.
I didn't see it.
I was just watching the replay.
That's a great play.
That's a .
Oh, my gosh.
You got that on video, too, didn't you?
That was crazy.
Dude, put that on that kid's highway tape.
I will.
He's bringing it back.
Stops all the time.
Oh, he just threw it back.
Oh, he did the right good job.
Good throw.
Yeah.
Two, one.
Watch the middle.
I got you.
Come on.
Ready?
Up.
Boom.
Three.
There you go.
Let's go.
.
One, two.
One more.
Ready?
.
Let's go.
Nice.
.
You call it fair at Mad Fox.
Jose, you want an Italian ice?
I was just going to buy one.
Yes, please.
I'll take one.
Well, then we open here.